معنا من روما المقرره الامميه لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه فرانشيسكا
البانز اهلا بك سيده فرانشيسكا بدايه ما
تعليقك على جلسه محكمه العدل الدوليه وما
تضمنته مرافعات الفريق القانوني لجنوب
افريقيا مرحبا وسيله لابد من القول انه
مررت بلحظات من العواطف والانفعال لانه
خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه كانت اشهر
صعبه جدا جدا وتع من الناحيه المهنيه
بالنسمه لي
فقد لاحظت الاعمال الرهيبه والمروع واحده
بعد الاخرى و ولم اشهد اطلاقا او الرد
الرد الضروري على المستوى الدولي من قبل
اممه المتحده نظرا لاعاده الكرامه لهؤلاء
الضحايا الكثار وللشعب المضطهد الذي يعاني
هذا هذا امر لا ينبغي ان يتحمله اي شعب او
اي شخص
وخاصه اثناء الصمت العالم الصمت
الممكن لم نكل تواطئ فعال من قبل بعض
الدول
الغربيه وشاهدنا قضه جنوب افريقيا من
النساء والرجال
يقدمون امام محكمه العدل الدوليه
وقضاتها سردا لما حصل ويبدو لي انها
محاوله لانقاذ ما تبقى من انسانيتنا ومن
القانون الدولي وكلاهما يتعرضان لخطر
الزوال والانتهاء تحت
اركام وانقاذ ما حصل من منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وقبل ذلك وهل باعتقادك اننا امام
بدايه تحرك
انساني دولي وفق الضغط قانوني ستفرض هذه
الدعوه التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا
اعتقد بالنظر الى طريقه عمل المحكمه
وبالنظر الى القانون الدولي
ومعاهده الاباده الجماعيه اهدافها
واغراضها ومعناها ف نق ومهمه الاجراءات
الموجوده في المعاهده و وولايه مثلا في
محاله
اوكرانيا ونيمار لا انا اعتقد او اتوقع ان
المحكمه العدل
الدوليه ستدعي الى ايقاف هذه
النشاطات وعلى الاقل كحد ادنى لان هذا هو
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يحاول انقاذ
المزيد من قتل الناس والجروح
والاصابات وبالتالي هذا هو هذه خطوه الحد
الادنى وبعد ذلك رغم ان ذلك ضروري لابد من
الضمان السياق السياسي يكون بطريقه بحيث
لا يحصل المزيد من الانتهاكات القانون
الدولي بما في
ذلك القرار اصدار قرار المحكمه
حتى الان اسرائيل في تعليقها على الجلسه
اليوم وصفت ذلك بالنفاق الاكبر في التاريخ
غدا هي سترد على الاتهامات المواجهه عليها
برايك اللا اي مدى
ستحاول تبرير جرائمها بالقول انها تدافع
عن نفسها وهل ما ارتكبته من جرائم في
غزه يؤكد
انها كانت تدافع عن نفسها بقتل هذا العدد
الكبير من
المدنيين انظروا انا قلت ذلك سابقا
اسرائيل لديها حق ان حمايه نفسها وليس
لديها حق ان تشن الحروب ضد
السكان الذين يعيشون تحت الاحتلال
اسرائيل ينبغي ان تتخذ اجراءات لمنع
الهجمات تعرض لهجمات من حماس او غيرها
وافضل الطريقه لذلك هو ان تحترم القانون
الدولي الاساسي وبالتالي السؤال الي حاليا
هو هل هل لابد ان ترد على ما قامت من
اعمال
بصراحه السؤال الان كذلك سيده
فرانشيسكا ما الذي يمكن ان تحققه هذه
المحكمه على ارض الواقع هناك مطالبات بوقف
هذه الاباده الجماعيه
في غزه من الناحيه الزمنيه هل سيطول الوضع
مع العلم ان كل يوم وكل ساعه تمر هناك
ضحايا جدد لاسرائيل
نعم بالضبط هذه النقطه اللي كنت احاول
شرحها وهي انه في جميع
الاحوال هناك حق لحمايه النفس لكن لكن هذا
لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى انهاء وقضاء على شعب
وفرض المجاعه على الشعوب اكثر من 3 الف
جثه قد جرى حسابها لحد الان وسيزيد العدد
بما ذلك 7000 الذين يجلسون منذ الاسابيع
وهناك جرحى هناك مئات من
الاطفال هناك هناك الف طفل لحد
الان جرى بتر اعضائهم دون التخدير والاف
الاطفال جرى بتر اعضائهم على الاقل الساق
واحده واحيانا ساقين
يوميا بصراحه ان الشيء المثير للصدمه هو
ان اسرائيل سمح لها بان تواصل هذه المذبحه
مره بعد
اخرى وليس ولس الامر ليس وهذا ليس مصلحه
اسرائيل و من اصلحه اسرائيل ايضا ان لا
ترتكب مثل هذه الجرائم الشنيعه مهما كان
قرار المحكمه الذي سيصدر برايك هل تتوقعين
ان تلتزم به اسرائيل والى اي مدى سيشكل
كذلك القرار ضغطا على الدول الداعمه
لاسرائيل
نعم من المهم جدا ان
نتذكر ان قرارات المحكمه العدل الدوليه
ملزمه وبالتالي
فهذا يعني ان الدول تكون مسؤوله اذا لم
تحترم وتطبق قرارات
المحكمه
وطبعا وهذا وهذا يتعلق بضع عفقا ثقيلا
على على دوله على اسرائيل وعلى الدول اللي
تدعم اسرائيل في هذه اللحظات
الماساويه شكرا جزيلا ل لك المقرره
الامميه لحقوق الانسان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه فرانشيسكا الب حدثنا من روما
شكرا لك